welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
just you the viewer and listener but the
man of my right who is been front and
center on American Ninja Warrior for
many many years it's the eleventh season
of this remarkable program Mondays at
8:00 Eastern on NBC
good to see you madam good to see you
brother I'm great thrilled to be here I
just flew in from Colorado's home with
my folks back in Denver and watching
some of the Rockies games and now back
in LA getting ready for this I love
Charlie Blackmon man he's such a Arenado
or just they've the fielding is
unbelievable the pitching is doing
better Coors Field so I grew up as a
baseball player Colorado and I never
knew how big the altitude was till break
we came to California and all of a
sudden I saw balls that I thought were
going 450 feet right infielders stepping
in together our outfielders stepping in
to catch up so I do not envy the
pitchers of course my first all-star
game I covered for ESPN was the one in
Colorado like 97 yeah and the homerun
Derby I remember McGwire was hitting
them 500 feet yeah that was it was like
Jim Thome I think ended holding my deck
I interviewed Thome and his big-ass
Popeye forearms and creatine when he's
gonna get out there at Coors Field it
was gonna be particularly ugly and I was
there that when they started talking
about we got to get a humidor yeah we
got to get walls and refrigerators put
on putting in the balls in a humidor to
try and add some form of humidity to try
and get the the baseballs
into it does it well of normal we need
to dome it and then just increase the
humidity to 90% so your ball will bite
we had he's got to be one of our
favorite guests right Charlie Blackmon
when he came here absolutely he had been
like I got a dinosaur sure is scrubbed
out to the max yeah he's great you know
and for baseball for baseball players to
like wake up early and come yeah down to
El Segundo
yeah it was neat he's he's a good egg
and I think you know Colorado covered
embers a great sports town it sure is
some Broncos now we embrace the players
who do well and I think
Blackman's Blackmun's gonna have a
bright feel way had his 59th birthday
over the weekend it's I was just in the
airport today where Elway Steakhouse is
driving by Elwes car dealerships and I
mean
if the guy wanted to be governor he
could be I'm sure he could yeah whatever
he wants he's the Duke I think he's
doing he's the Duke he is the Dukie I
mean John John Elway for sure I'll say
this to you I said this to Akbar say
this to you two the number of times I
walk into a room in my house and my kids
are glued to American Ninja I have lost
it's unbelievable it really what's great
is as we watch these young kids and a
lot of whom you know still like baseball
our traditional sports but maybe don't
play it or don't watch it as much right
that they really are embracing Ninja
Warrior we have American Ninja wary
Junior on universal kids we're about to
film that in a couple weeks and and
watching these kids get on the course
and seeing how good they are right how
athletic they are and and again when you
look at like Tamika Catchings coming out
we've we've got these unbelievable
stories so people who were at home these
kids whether you're tall you're sure
whether you are a great athlete or
whether you're dealing with hearing
impairment issues whatever you're gonna
find someone on the show who's gone
through the same issues right same
challenges you have and I think there's
there's something for these kids that
that they just I think they like that
they like seeing themselves on the show
I think it's also just a the course
itself and the way it's shot and the
fans going crazy it is visually striking
and I think kids really get into that
and they love also seeing the
splashdowns yeah it is it is intense and
it is just like the way that that these
athletes achieve and what it means to
them to achieve it really is just
awesome fun yeah
television that I know my kids are not
gonna get verbally you know assaulted
right all right they're just gonna sit
there and enjoy it they can't get enough
nobody's begging the refs like Katie
flopping get used to that Brooklyn
nobody is complaining about the
officiating they direct and I think
again you know I know this is saying a
lot but in terms of NBC families of
network on cable you might be on more
than law and order right now it's and
that is saying something you know it's
it's unbelievable when when you
everywhere and people will too you know
we'll see photos of people
watching it because a lot of people
don't watch TV the traditional way
anymore as you know other than NFL
pretty much your sports yes that's good
to have a ninja on ubiquitously on
multiple channels right and and to have
people still enjoying it and to people
embracing these athletes and and seeing
these athletes now build careers out of
it it's it's awesome I was just home in
Colorado where ninja nation these gyms
are opening up and a lot of our ninjas
are there teaching the next generation
of kids including my my friends kids are
now getting into this and I was with my
niece and her friend was like you're on
TV she goes I feel like I'm sitting next
to Ellen DeGeneres I said I am relatable
I get that you are really I couldn't
believe it I was like really we're
having tacos here this is I'm amazed
that it's amazed at people care it is it
is it is really amazing and the success
has just been spectacular I'll ask you
the same question asked Akbar the folks
who come up with the course what drugs
are they on it is it's it's so
unbelievable and what's really cool is
we actually have kids we have an
obstacle design challenge where people
can submit obstacles and some of our
best obstacles we had an 11 year old
girl who designed our most challenging
obstacle in Vegas the one that ninjas
love the most and that takes a lot of
them out and it's so cool seeing people
we have a staff that works year-round to
try to figure out ways to challenge
these athletes yes and to do it for
people who are 4 foot 11 to Tamika
Catchings you know world-class athletes
in different ways and to figure out how
to push them to the limit but still make
it possible yes
and it's an exact science we never know
how it's gonna play until people get on
the course so Deb you ever attempted it
yeah you're 40 went a lot better than I
broke my foot I shattered my foot trying
a trampoline
come on fell into the water in front of
all the ninjas and it's it's so bad when
you're out there you you know I'm the
voice of the sport yes I'm ostensibly
the expert and then you see me fail so
awfully my credibility with them was
just have you ever seen me at the
combine because I can I can relate to
what you just said about feelings
particularly this looks like your
silhouette looks like the fugitive well
you you find that man rich
and and you could see the silhouette I
will admit this they that I that the the
right leg normally is flailed out a
little bit more right there may have
been some generous editing there's been
maybe some form of photo Jerry West W in
the run Matt Iseman here on the Rich
Eisen show let's talk about IVA live yes
that's coming up on history Sunday July
seventh this is some old-school fun type
of stuff it really is so this came out
last year with travis pastrana wanted to
pay homage to Evel Knievel so last year
in Las Vegas live on television he
recreated three of his most iconic jumps
culminating in he jumped the fountain
and he did it on a bike a three hundred
seventy pound bike similar to what evil
did and you know put his life and limb
on the line and this year they're
elevating it so we're gonna have this
awesome stud of a woman Vikki golden who
was the first woman ever to do a
backflip on a bike she's going through
13 firewalls and the record was 10 and
it's 2002 Gray's when he went through
firewalls and then the final jump of the
night 22 year old kid axel Hodges is
going to attempt to set the world
jumping the distance record which
currently 386 he's looking to go well
over a football field in the air on a
motorcycle and imagine it's gonna be
live we're shooting out at San
Bernardino Airport because that was the
only place we found that could have a
long enough to run it for him to get up
to speed but it I was out there I was
out there on Friday we were testing and
my heart was in my throat the entire
time watching this kid test and he was
he was even close to the distance but
you're just going this kid is putting
everything on the line live right for
our entertainment it's and to push the
envelope man to be a part of history so
if if you're trying to fly into the San
Bernardino Airport on Sunday night we're
gonna we're gonna be the least in the
air pronounced thing I think is is
feeling like I'm the same age as you are
just about and
and watching like you remember when Evel
Knievel was jumping on Wide World of
Sports
those were must-see TV well I mean one
of the most famous pieces of video is
him that the agony of his default when
he had landed you know and see you know
who shot that you know who's behind the
camera we heard this before but get me
who was bo Derek because John Derek was
shooting it and bo Derek was the one who
got that iconic image of Evel Knievel
rag dolling over the handlebars like
Cesar's right she was the one shooter a
freak description ragdoll that was it
like he had no spine it was just totally
he was jelly when he landed his wipeouts
you know that that was at a distance of
about a hundred forty feet this kids
looking to go you know closer to 400
feet maybe and and it's it's uh it's
insane when you watch these athletes
just they want to push the envelope
right they want to fly farther faster do
higher and it's awesome it's awesome to
see these people who are just wired
differently yeah that's on history
coming up Sunday July 7th I love it
history think of grainy World War 1
video right right this motorcycle here
yeah it's it's survived this crash Evel
Knievel in amaze he barely barely did oh
yeah smashed bones was in the hospital
for five you've never seen this video
Derek do my god dude no joke yeah it is
it's one of those ones where your heart
is in your throat the whole time we just
watch it watching the wipeout but
knowing the guy got back on his bike and
that's the same all of these athletes
have taken you know had their injuries
and I'm to see them get back out it's
give it that KD in 2023 look I don't
know how into Denver Nuggets basketball
you were this year but they were
terrific and watch and they are they
they're they're they just paid they piz
aid jamal murray they're not they're not
losing them they're the state they're
gonna stay intact it's been a long night
back man I remembers the early 90s when
we we came back from to down to beat
Seattle
and that was like the last time I felt
the Nuggets really good he was dismayed
I remember the Alex English Dan Issel
Nuggets a horse status Dan Issel right I
mean they were really good they scored
like 190 points and died it was Yeah
right it was double dribble on on
Nintendo and they were they were fun to
watch and just seeing the Nuggets last
year given and given some game seven run
for some money because it felt like the
West has just been you know it's been
the Lakers the the Warriors the Rockets
the Thunder the Denver just even with
good teams the West has been so Dom see
that's why again I'll just quickly hit
this again if Kauai signs with the
Lakers this I don't think the NBA fan
base wants this and I just that that's
not what we want like he if he stays put
in Toronto or he joins the Clippers now
we're talking about a totally like it
really is chess pieces up in the air
going into next season right as to
what's gonna happen with the NBA Finals
period like Western and Eastern
Conference ad just does he want to come
and possibly be you know sharing the
fiddle or second fiddle this is why Kay
dila and I don't know why
III think KD I'm glad he went to the
nets and not the Knicks because I think
it would have been why would you leave
the best team the best teammates the
best coach the best GM a team that's
been in the finals to go to the Knicks
well because the Nets was a good you
know and the answer to that is because
the Knicks have a history a significant
history and a remarkable arenas KD alive
with no that's the point that's the
point it's totally remember Willis Reed
stumble again no he probably doesn't
even remember you know Michael Ray
Richardson limping in or Bernard King no
in the mid 80s when he went back Starks
upholstering joy I mean Starks Starks
going even one for for 17 1 for 16 9 he
would have been 7 right so I mean it's a
total and again Kyrie Irving saying they
members when the
when the Nets made the 2003 finals
really good was he a big kid matumbo fan
like well come on as soon as he signed
he went to you too but he goes what Nets
game it was the first result you know we
should do we should we shouldn't
basically say because we only have one
more segment left in the show we should
invite any Nets fan like legitimately
Nets fan to call in to the show tomorrow
and introduce him or herself to us Jets
fan Nets Nets like a met fan like
they're firemen I don't even know I
don't know honestly I can't even you
don't know one no I don't know we're say
pre jay-z fan we don't want you know
jay-z would call it that big even the
same thing where you're like I remember
the 2003 Nets championship like and we
should come up el Zorro our researcher
pardon me for spending the last couple
minutes of your that we should come up
with like a list of trivia questions
yeah just to prove like you can't just
call in and say all right I remember the
Nets like Derrick Coleman de Nets yeah
chest yeah test your net hood
show us your net hood meet your Nets
maybe that's not theirs either good to
see you brother good see you thanks for
coming on now Williams but well buck
Williams was terrific man buck Williams
is a great berry played for the net dr.
J dr. and again even when he was there
with the ABA you want to talk about Dan
is right even when he was with the Otis
birdsong I remember Christmas surprise
all second fiddle man yeah they were all
second fiddle not anymore
Michael Ray Richardson played for the
nets oh I know I did your Mike Jim
Minsky by sorry I'm just reading away
Mike Jim Minsky very few very few
players have a gene in him to start
their last name next to each other
he was the best ever dad my Iseman on
both Twitter and Instagram check out
American Ninja Warrior Mondays at 8:00
Eastern Time
hey by the way
not a bad back-to-back few Sunday July
evil lives and then in the next episode
of ninja warriors my parents gonna be
watching a lot of the Iceman's they're
felling I should dig fell in a way very
good for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app